is this connective fermions and bosons
so this was what happens is what seems
to happen okay
it's you know subject to revision next
even next few days
but what seems to be the case is that uh
bosons
are associated with essentially merging
in multi-way graphs
and fermions are associated with
branching in multi-way graphs
and that essentially the exclusion
principle
is the fact that in branchial space
things have a certain extent in bronze
shield space
that in which things are being sort of
forced apart in branchial space whereas
the case of bosons they get they
they come together in bronchial space
and the real question is can we explain
the relationship between that and these
things called spinners
which are the representation of half
integer spin particles that have this
weird feature that usually when you go
around 360 degree rotation
you get back to where you started from
but for a spinner you don't get back to
where you started from
it takes 720 degrees of rotation to get
back to where you started from
and we are just i feels like we are
we're just
incredibly close to actually having that
understanding how that works
and it turns out it looks like my
current speculation is
that it's as simple as the uh
directed hypergraphs versus undirected
hypergraphics
uh the relationship between spinners and
vectors so which is just
interesting yeah that'll be interesting
if these are all these kind of uh
nice properties of this multi-way graphs
of
branching and representation spinners
have been very mysterious
and if that's what they turn out to be
there's going to be an easy explanation
yeah
it's direct versus and directed it's
just and that's why
there's only two different cases it's
why are spinners important in uh quantum
mechanics can you just give a
uh yeah so spinners are important
because they are um
they're the representation of electrons
which have half integer spin
they are the the wave functions of
electrons
are spinners just like the wave
functions of photons are vectors
the wave functions of electrons are
spinners
and and they have this property that
when you
rotate by by 360 degrees they come back
to minus one
of themselves and take 720 degrees to
get back
to the original value and and they are a
consequence of
of um uh and we usually think of of
of rotation in space as being you know
when you have this notion of rotational
invariance
and rotational invariance as we
ordinarily experience
it doesn't have the feature you know if
you go through 360 degrees you go back
to where you started from
but that's not true for electrons and so
that's
that's why understanding how that works
is important yeah i've been playing with
mobius
uh strip quite a bit lately just for fun
yes it adds some funk it has the same
kind of funky property yes right exactly
you can have there's the so-called belt
trick which is this way of taking an
extended object
and you can see properties like spinners
with that kind of extended object
that um yeah it would be very cool if
there's it somehow connects the
directive versus undirected i think
that's what it's going to be
something's going to be as simple as
that but we'll see i mean this is this
is the thing that
that you know this is the big sort of
bizarre surprise is that you know
because you know i i i learned physics
as probably
let's say let's say a fifth generation
in the sense that you know if you go
back to the 1920s and so on there were
the people who were originating
quantum mechanics and so on maybe it's a
little less than that maybe i was like
a a third generation or something i
don't know but but you know the people
from whom i learned physics were the
people who were you know have been
students of the students of the
the people who originated the the
current understanding of physics
and we're now at you know probably the
seventh generation of physicists
or something from the from the early
days of 20th century physics
and you know whenever a field gets that
many generations deep
it seems the foundations seem quite
inaccessible
and they seem you know it seems like you
can't possibly understand that we've
gone through
you know seven academic generations and
that's been you know that's been this
thing that's been difficult to
understand for
for that long it just can't be that
simple
you